now Joe while Joe's at the beach under
his little umbrella that chair by the
way he has a hard time moving it
probably somebody should help him well
Florida Governor DeSantis he's been hard
at work that's what leaders do in times
of Crisis they show up they get to work
natural disasters don't take a break
during your holiday weekend and today on
Twitter the first lady of Florida Casey
DeSantis she posted this picture on
Twitter it's a fallen 100 year old oak
tree at the governor's mansion where the
first lady of Florida and her children
were at the time luckily thank God
nobody was injured from this fallen tree
but the death toll in Florida Georgia
the Carolinas sadly it's expected to
rise I hope it doesn't our prayers are
with everyone in the Southeast tonight
all right joining us now at the very
latest from his home state actually the
free state of Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis uh wow 100 year old oak tree
I'm sure a little scary for you and your
family Governor but the devastation that
that I saw this morning on TV what's
your assessment at this hour
well Sean we were ready for this so we
had a search and rescue team staged
National Guard we had 5500 National
Guard we had 1.2 million gallons of
gasoline in the event of fuel shortages
we had over 30 000 linemen to restore
power and so as soon as the storm passed
uh our First Responders were on the
scene checking on people the good news
is is that we have not seen the type of
loss of life like we did at Hurricane
Ian in the coastal areas they did
experience significant storm surge most
of the people did evacuate and so we're
cautiously optimistic that we're going
to end up okay on that and the storm hit
landfall probably about 8 A.M this
morning we've since restored 370
000 power to customers and there's about
000 outstanding so all those linemen
have been working to get people back
Connected we know that there's going to
be a lot of things we need to do but we
want to get everybody back on their feet
as quickly as possible my understanding
is that the storm surge was great but it
receded quicker than than most people
were predicting true
yeah look I think that I mean this was a
category 4 storm all the way up until
maybe about 15 miles on the coast and
then it went to a high cat three so it
did uh drive up a lot of storm surge in
some of the areas uh some of it over
seven eight feet uh I think maybe even
10 feet but I think that People
Protected themselves when hurricane Ian
had you remember that down in Southwest
Florida and I know you know that area
well you know there were frantic calls
to 9-1-1 because the water was rising in
people's homes so quickly we did not see
those types of phone calls like we did
in Hurricane Ian and so I think it's a
combination of the surge was a little
bit more manageable and I think it was a
combination of people did heed the
evacuation warnings they got off the
barrier islands and they got to places
that were on higher ground and not
susceptible to The Surge I mean go back
to last year's hurricane and and Fort
Myers and Sanibel
I mean it was utter Devastation you just
never know what these hurricanes however
I mean being prepared having everybody
in place getting electrical power up
especially tomorrow I understand it's
supposed to be extremely hot in Florida
tomorrow that means older people
especially they're going to need their
air conditioners working it looks like
you're on track to get everybody up and
running as soon as possible
yeah we've got um a lot of linemen that
are there to help with the and a lot of
this part of Florida that's without
power a lot of these are like rural
cooperatives uh other types of Municipal
electrical so they may not have as much
resources as some of the private
companies uh like a Florida Power and
Light so we have all these extra linemen
that are there to offer the assistance
and we want to get that done as quickly
as possible there are going to be some
areas because there's massive amounts of
debris with all the forests and
everything like that some of the power
lines got chopped up pretty good so some
of it's going to take a little bit more
time than others will but the bottom
line is we have an overwhelming number
of personnel that are on the ground uh
working to restore everybody across the
board
let me ask you about a problem that has
emerged there was an article in the
paper today about in the New York Post
and and there have been other articles
I've read about this based on the number
of hurricanes and the amount of damage
uh the homeowners insurance especially
in coastal areas have gone up anywhere
from 25 30 or even higher and it is
especially in this recession this Biden
economy it is forcing people to
self-insure uh because the premiums are
up you know so significantly is there
anything that maybe the on the state
level you can do the federal government
needs to do to to deal with the rising
costs that are dramatically higher costs
for insuring your home
we've done a number of reforms in the
last year Sean including my safe Florida
home program people can get grants to
fortify their homes and make
improvements and then they get lower
rates we also did huge reforms in the
structure of our Market earlier this
year what that has led to is we now have
four new companies that are actually
entering into Florida's property
insurance Market which was not happening
for so many years and we've got a fifth
company on Deck I mean as you know you
need to have consumers need to have
choices that's how you keep premium
increases in check so we've got four in
the hopper one on the way and I think
you may when this hurricane season is
over have more companies that are going
to be willing to get in the market but
we've had a lot of issues with inflation
generally as you know and then
particularly having hurricane Ian which
is one of the most costly storms in the
history of the United States
all right Governor our prayers are with
the people of my future State and I mean
it uh Florida our prayers are with
everybody tonight and uh we will be
following closely thank you for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else